[Music]
are you guys ready for a lady game
always it is called the wheel of cheap
wine we're each gonna take turns
spinning the wheel it's gonna land on
one of our names underneath our names
are very salacious questions we either
have to answer the mission or take a
shot of this delicious wine who wants to
start
Keltie I think our guests should so I'm
gonna spin for you okay if Jarrod asks
you to marry him tonight
would you say yes oh the wine [ __ ]
drink the wine drink the wine bring the
wine you can't she can't say that I
can't how was the wine okay ready which
Bachelorette didn't deserve their own
season Hannah
B have you even met her no why are they
making this hype up Hannah B you don't
know her I really have hyped up her
season I'm just saying that cuz I don't
know her yet I'll tell you who didn't
deserve their season though Kailyn
Ashley her bear
who she was on my season okay oh Emily
won yeah she should have been the
Bachelorette yeah she was eventually
after they broke up then they went to
spy V and they're like do you want to be
the Bachelorette and she said no she had
a boyfriend at the time so then they
went to Ashley her boyfriend what I went
on The Bachelor yeah his name is Trevor
he was great you can good Trevor that's
a boy yes not us Trevor firefighter
break I ever doesn't answer call Jason I
want to talk to him FaceTime Jason okay
I want to talk to him okay he's in the
office yeah how does he facing we have a
95
Jason we're filming you so don't say
okay Jason do you think Caitlin is the
one oh my god last question are you
intimidated by how strong and powerful
Caitlin is as a lady you're gonna make a
beautiful trophy husband love you
he's cute the hottest thing he ever did
was when we were tummy celery and put it
towards our own he goes I could do
better than Neil Diamond's can you do
better than Neil Lane if you don't even
know what Neil Ian is okay marry kill
Jenna Ushkowitz okay Kevin McHale Lea
Michele hot
okay I'm gonna marry Lea cuz she's the
richest I'm gonna I'm gonna this is the
point in the game we wanted to go here
wine
all right Kaitlyn thank you so much for
being here thank you for coming by good
luck in your marriage to Jason and you
shouldn't be oh we approve of Jason
cheers hey love you guys for having
while yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]